Blake and Gwen and wait until you see  what happens when Gwen returns to the  boys to see America's favorite couple  fight it out I'm probably gonna pay for  this later sorry Blake he looks like  winds got a new bestie Kelly Clarkson  just launched against the pros why are  you doing this to me Kelly's pulling  double-duty between the voice and her  new talk show which debuts in three  weeks today she gave fans  behind-the-scenes look at her set this  is the band space look at it don't you  want to come here by the show hold on  sir now we're told every show will open  with Kelly singing a song chosen by her  audience of about 200 people oh and from  the looks at the bloopers Kelly will  also be super unfiltered I'm so nervous  throat's about cinema I bit my tongue  what let's do it again  punch me in the face everything's fine  my Mike Peck fell off my bro I'm not  proper nothing about this is classy I  don't know what I said but I stand by it  you  [Music]